♪ (intro music) ♪
Hello, everyone.
My name is Igor, I'm going to...
I work in TensorFlow team
and I'm going to talk to you today
about distributed TensorFlow.
Well, why would you care
about distributed TensorFlow?
Many of you know the answer probably.
But just in case,
it's a way for your models
to train faster and be more parallel.
It's a way for you
to get more things done.
It's read quicker.
When you train deep learning models,
it can take a long time.
And when I say a long time,
I mean weeks.
With all the available hardware
to you out there,
scaling up to hundreds of CPUs
or GPUs can really make a difference.
How could you scale up?
Well, you could just add a GPU
to your machine.
In this case, this is just plug and play.
You insert the GPU, TensorFlow
handles all the details for you,
and you see a nice bump
in the training speed.
You could also insert multiple GPUs.
In this case, you'd have
to write additional code.
You need to replicate your model,
you need to combine gradients
from every GPU,
and if you're using batch norm layer,
you have the tricky question of what
to do with the statistics on each GPU.
The point I'm trying to make is
that you need to do additional work
to make this work,
and you need to learn stuff
that you didn't plan in learning.
You can also use multiple machines.
And this situation is
similar to the one before,
but in this case, your bottleneck
is probably going to be that communication
between the machines.
You'll start thinking
about minimizing that communication,
and probably doing more work luckily.
For example, combining the gradients
on the local GPUs
before exchanging them
with a remote GPUs.
Unless specialized
networking hardware is used,
the coordination cost in this setup
are probably going to limit your scaling.
But there is an approach,
there's a solution to this.
This approach is called parameter server.
Some hosts we call them parameter servers,
they're going to only
hold training weights.
Other hosts, workers,
they're going to have
a copy of the TensorFlow graph.
They're going to get their own input,
compute their own gradient,
and then just go ahead
and update the training weights
without any coordination
with other workers.
So this is an approach
with low coordination
between a large number of hosts.
And there you go,
this scales well
and we've been doing this at Google
for a long time.
But there is a wrinkle with this approach.
You give up synchronicity
and that has benefits.
And if you think about
the parameter server approach,
it's an approach from the CPU era
with all the reliable communication
between GPUs.
we can consider designs
which have tighter coupling
and more coordination
between the workers.
One such approach is
based on all-reduce .
That's not a new idea.
The general goal of all-reduce
is to combine all the values
and distribute results
to all the processes.
All-reduce is kind of tricky
to explain on the slide,
but you can think of its results
as reduce operation
followed by a broadcast operation.
But don't think of it that way
in terms of performance.
It's a fused algorithm
and it's way more efficient
than those two operations together.
In addition to it,
hardware vendors...
hardware vendors often supply specialized
or reduce implementations
that TensorFlow can secretly use
behind the scenes to help you.
Alternative approaches,
they typically send all data
to a central place.
All-reduce is not going
to have such a bottleneck,
because it distributes coordination
between GPUs way more evenly.
With every tick of all-reduce,
each GPU sends and receives
a part of the final answer.
So how could all-reduce
help us with our models?
Well, consider...
let's say you have two GPUs.
You copied layers
and the variables on average GPU,
and you perform the forward pass.
Nice and parallel.
But then during the backward pass,
as the gradients become available,
we can use all-reduce
to combine those gradients
with their counterparts from other GPUs.
In addition to that,
because of the way...
In addition to that gradients
from the outer layers
are available before the gradients
from the other layers.
So we could overlap backward propagation,
computation and/or reduce communication.
That gives you even more steps per second.
The bottom line is when communication
between GPUs is reliable,
all-reduce can be fast
and allow you to scale well.
How could you use all-reduce
in TensorFlow?
Well, so far in this talk I told you
that to take advantage of multiple GPUs,
you need to write additional code,
change your model
and learn stuff.
Chances are you're using--
you're following our advice
of using the highest level API
that works for your use case.
That probably is estimator.
With estimator, your model is
specified by the model function,
and it has no knowledge
about GPUs or devices.
So to have that model use multiple GPUs,
you just need to add one line.
You need to pass an instance
of a new class called mirror strategy.
And mirror strategy
is one implementation
of our new distribution strategy API.
Distribution strategy tells
TensorFlow how to replicate your model.
Oops, sorry!
Another thing I want to say is
that mirror strategy
takes a number of--
could take a number of GPUs
or a list of GPUs to use,
or you can not give it
any arguments at all
and then it will just
figure out what GPUs to use.
Mirror strategy works in the way
exactly as I described before.
It replicates your model,
it uses all-reduce for communication.
So gradient updates from every GPUs,
from all GPUs, they're going to be
combined before updating the weights.
and each copy of your model on every
GPU is part of a single TensorFlow graph.
That means this is in-graph replication
with synchronous training
that uses all-reduce on many GPUs.
Now the last 10 minutes
are kind of a waste of time for you
if this doesn't perform well.
And it does perform well.
As you add GPUs,
this implementation scales well.
We have a team at TensorFlow
that specifically works
on fast implementations of averages
for various machine configurations,
and this implementation
gets 90% scaling on eight GPUs.
And again, it didn't require any change
to the user's model.
It didn't require any change
because we changed
everything in TensorFlow
that's not your model.
Things like optimizer,
batch_norm, summaries.
Everything that writes state
now needs to become distribution-aware.
That means that it has to learn
how to combine its state with other GPUs.
And this is important
because alternative API is out there.
They typically ask you
to rephrase your model
to supply optimizers,
for example, separately,
so that they can do all
the state coordination behind the scenes.
And if you have some experience
with training your models
on multiple GPUs,
you might be wondering,
"Well, can I save my model
on a computer with eight GPUs
and then do an evaluation on it
on a computer with, say, no GPUs?"
Typically this causes a problem,
but with distribution strategy API,
we maintain the backward compatibility
on the checkpoint level,
so mirror strategy it has multiple
copies of the state on every GPU,
and that state is in sync.
So mirror strategy is going
to save only one copy,
and then at the restore time,
it's only going to restore that state
to required number of GPUs.
So this use case is supported.
Distribution strategy works
with Eager mode as well,
but we are still
fine-tuning the performance,
and distribution strategy
is a very general API
that I hope in the future
will support many use cases.
it's not tied to estimator,
and we are working in two ways
of creating even more better APIs
based on distribution strategy.
We in the future...
soon, pretty soon...
we intend to support many kinds
of distributed training.
Synchronous, Asynchronous
multi-node, model parallelism,
all of that is going to be supported based
as part of distribution strategy API.
But until then, for multi-node solution,
please continue using
estimator.train_and_evaluate,
or try Horovod!*
That's an outstanding community project
that also offers a multi-node solution.
Mirror strategies are available
for you in our nightly build.
And we are very, very
actively working on it,
And it's a product of work of many people.
And I would really
encourage you to try it out,
and let us know
what do you think about it
via Github
or talk to us after my talk.
Alright, thank you,
thanks for your attention.
(applause)
♪ (outro music) ♪